and I guess part of this too is as you
as you think about this like are there
elements that you can use the data for
whether it's investing or other
applications than just putting in a
database and selling a subscription to
it or is it really just hey we've come
up with a very kind of clever unique way
to take that audio put it into a
database and the best way to monetize
that is by some of those subscriptions
so that was the first piece but what I
started realizing is a lot of these
founders would then rely on me for
benchmarking data which then they said
Nathan can you help me with my board
deck can you help me raise can you help
me sell and so I help these companies
you know I would you know hundreds of
millions of dollars worth of deals right
whether it's raising selling whatever or
buying other companies over like between
2016 and 2018 and 2018 I said you know
what I should start doing some of these
deals myself so I started writing checks
into the C funds as an LP and watching
how the VC funds analyze these companies
to learn and I realized wow I think the
real opportunity here is actually to
create an a new asset class and what I
mean by that is you know software today
you know Salesforce really brought it in
I would say twenty two thousand seven
eight ish but there's now a standard set
of metrics that every software company
private or public should be tracking
right you know obviously mo our growth
AR our growth CAC churn our Pugh net
expansion network there's probably 20
key metrics and if you have all those
metrics for a large amount of companies
you can start generating a credit score
for SAS companies and you can in loan
against the credit score or if I don't
do the loan directly I can sell the
credit score to a bank or to the C firm
who's running diligence on the company
with the founders permission and so this
credit score is you asked is it just a
clever way to create the podcast to
create a database the answer is at first
yes sure to make money but now what I'm
doing is I'm using this massive data set
we're tracking about 20 billion dollars
in real-time revenue from private b2b
SAS companies via their plat connection
to our tech stocks so we have direct
access to their bank accounts we
generate a credit score and then we help
them raise capital really really cheap
based off the strength of
credit score and that's a lot of more
growing and keeping more of their
companies via the old route which was
again raised VC hope you own 5% when you
go public yeah and there's obviously a
number of companies that are starting to
do this and I think that it's incredibly
clever because of you know your point
about no I want a new asset class but
also to the ability to get the data
right there was always data there for a
lot of these companies now you can
actually get it through a technological
solution what do you think the risk is
or if you looked at this and how to play
kind of devil's advocate with yourself
what is the thing that you're like hey
here's where we could mess this up or
here's where it could actually be a
negative thing that to kind of counter
all of those positive aspects of you try
and study history alright so you study
Milken and junk bonds you studied
general just debt and how debt is using
governments and you just you just try
and study debt historically and so the
critical things with any debt is you
have to establish what your loss ratio
is gonna be which is a bit of a trick
question when you're raising capital
because if someone asks you what's your
lost ratio and you say we haven't had
any losses they're gonna say well your
sample size isn't big enough
you should have losses and if you say
you have a 1 to 2% loss rate which is
you know generally healthy for people
with large you know loan tape debt books
they're gonna say oh well you have one
or two percent losses it's not good so
you can't win answering that question
it's a bad question that being said what
I'm trying to do is build a structure
where I can deploy capital in disasters
you know less than 60 seconds after they
connect their bank account with our tech
stack because I can run the credit score
very quick so I don't need an
underwriting team I don't need a fancy
office space it's just a credit score
and when you add up all the private
software companies in the world today
there's a lot of different estimations
on what that total value might be worth
but you can just look at the public SAS
market look at the best more venture
index I mean this is gonna be multi
trillion that trillions and trillions of
dollars here over the next ten to twenty
years a software continues to eat the
world I want to be the guy that has the
best data on software business risk
which will make me than that hopefully
the top source were debt into that space
and so I want to build you know 100 200
billion dollar debt portfolio in just
software companies over the next call it
you know decade
two decades and do you ever have any
aspirations to go outside of the sass
companies whether it's into e-commerce
or other types of subscription
businesses or do you really feel like
that SAS niche is big enough and also
kind of the sweet spot for you the
question I spend a lot of time ask
myself is what is my unique advantage
like what is the the moat that I've
built the distribution moat that I
currently have built is totally focused
on software the magazine the database
the podcast it's all software it's not
the e-commerce show it's not the
e-commerce magnet's software that's
right hub there's a massive advantage so
for the foreseeable future
I'm gonna hyper focus on software and by
the way there are so many great products
for like e-commerce brands whether it's
PayPal cash stripe is now doing advances
on your daily revenue they're companies
like clear bank that have raised a lot
of money that are doing you know two
month four month terms on your Facebook
ad spend via you know Shopify just
launched Shopify money you saw our
friend Danko just joined Shopify
full-time to help build that so by the
way everyone's gonna get into this space
you're just like AWS is gonna start you
know doing more loans against AWS spend
this is gonna be a very popular thing
what I'm gonna try and do is loan money
we're two software companies where there
are no restrictions on how they spend it
you can spend it on people you can spend
on your Facebook Aspen or you can spend
it on your AWS spend but my goal is
because I have the largest data set is
that I can best price the software
companies risk of default and because of
my best pricing algo I can give them the
cheapest price and in this space in my
opinion pump because I'm not like a VC
selling my network value if you take my
money it's really just who can give you
the cheapest capital so I think this is
a beautiful like thing to leverage for
me which is if capital is actually how
you scale like that is the network
effect as long as you have the asset of
the data you can win and I do think debt
into software it's going to be a
zero-sum game there will be one winner
because whoever builds the most loan
tape the fastest can get back leveraged
collateralized secure eyes the loans
drive their costs down and pass the
savings on to founders